I often discuss the negative impacts that pop culture media can have on people's
attitudes and opinions,
but if entertainment can propagate harmful ideas,
then it stands to reason that it can also have positive effects on our lives.
So in this video,
I want to focus on media that fosters empathy and solidarity.
Now admittedly,
that's a pretty broad category.
So to narrow it down,
I'll be highlighting a handful of my favorite movies from my most formative
years,
the 1980s
looking at Hollywood today,
it's pretty clear that the 1980s are back in a big way.
The current nostalgia craze is largely driven by Hollywood's obsession with
remakes,
reboots,
sequels,
and loving homages to popular 80th franchises.
The apex of this wave of nostalgia comes in the form of the novel turned
blockbuster ready player one,
I was born in 2025 but I wish I had grown up in the 1980s Ernest Cline's book.
And by extension,
the film is built around a long list of superficial and rather ostentatious
references to Kiki pop culture entertainment.
As a boy who grew up in the 1980s most of the media that's named dropped and
ready player one I remember well the Goonies Gremlins,
weird science tron back to the future.
I watched them all,
but thinking back to my childhood,
the cinematic moments that had the most profound impact on me and my emotional
development weren't necessarily from the most popular,
were iconic movies,
the movies scenes that left the biggest impression on my young mind.
We're unapologetically sappy and sentimental.
Goodbye Charlie.
They're the moments that still put a lump in my throat,
the ones that make my eyes water and my heart swell
like big
dog
movie critic Roger Ebert Once said that movie is our empathy generating machines
by which he meant that we as viewers identify with the characters on the screen
and that helps us understand experiences and perspectives other than our own
movies can also affirm the human spirit by showing us examples of what empathy
and solidarity looked like.
Empathy is the ability to understand and share the feelings or emotions of
others.
Now it's important to note that empathy isn't just feeling bad for the
misfortunes of other people.
Empathy is about feeling what others are feeling.
Solidarity is when people from diverse backgrounds find a common cause and then
work together to achieve social change.
You can think of solidarity as empathy put into collective action.
So with those two definitions in mind,
here's my personal list of five lesser known movies from the 1980s that helped
shape our humanity.
The journey of Natty Gan chronicles the adventures of a young woman and her
canine companion as they hop freight trains from Chicago to Washington state in
a quest to find her father
set against the backdrop of the Great Depression.
This is a quiet film with beautiful cinematography that shows us the world
through the eyes of characters living in poverty.
The film makers deliberately place us as the audience firmly on the side of the
downtrodden as we see police evicting impoverished families and company bosses,
treating workers with heartless difference.
But while this depression era world is harsh,
it's not defined by cynicism.
That was nice.
Acts of kindness and solidarity between economically oppressed people are
highlighted throughout the movie.
There's food in here and money for a chicken.
No,
Charlie,
don't tell me no.
The journey of Natty Gan is also reminiscent of the classic a boy and his dog
adventure stories genre except here the boy is a girl and the dog is a wolf.
It's especially important for young women to be represented as leads in their
own adventure stories and I'd argue that it's just as it Portland for young male
audiences to see these kinds of representations.
That's a nice dog.
He's a wolf.
Boys need to learn to identify with female characters and see women and girls as
fully human equals with their own stories.
NASA of the Valley of the wind is set 1000 years after humans have destroyed
civilization and the planet in a great apocalyptic war.
We follow the adventures of a young woman named Nassa princess of one of the few
remaining human kingdoms and she struggles to understand and heal a world that's
been overrun by Newton creatures and toxic forests.
Take home whatever you do,
don't start open.
The story is centers on NASA because struggle to restore equilibrium to the
environment and to end the violent conflicts between human tribes and the giant
insects of the jungle.
We are not your enemies.
We mean you know hard
in group depictions of empathy for friends,
teammates and family members are common in pop culture.
Media stories built around expressions of outgroup empathy that is empathy for
strangers or outsiders to your own group are more unusual
and expressions of empathy for one's enemies are especially rare.
Stop it.
Oh,
this killing my stock
and empathy for the enemy is really the guiding principle of this film.
Sorry.
Is there any way you can forgive us?
You've treated you so badly.
NASA remains acutely aware of the danger posed by the gigantic bug light
creatures,
but she nonetheless extends her empathy to these mutant beasts and it's that act
of empathy that ultimately saves humanity.
It has a range of 7,000 miles and a 20 mega ton warhead.
Amazing grace and chuck is about a small town boy who refuses to keep playing
little league baseball because of the existence of nuclear weapons and what the
hell is it?
[inaudible]
just can't play,
can't play because of nuclear weapons.
What's that got to do with baseball?
Nothing.
What's my best thing?
I have to give up something.
I feel real bad about this.
You know that
God games all that Dave,
we foreclosures,
his protest inspires the professional basketball star.
Amazing grace to join his strike and together they organize a global movement
for nuclear disarmament.
Alright.
Hollywood very rarely gets political activism,
right?
The depiction of activism in most movies is limited to raising awareness or
personal acts of defiance.
Amazing grace and chuck on the other hand,
manage just to show how social change actually happens.
Social change is brought about when organizers raised social costs higher and
higher until it becomes more advantageous for the powers that be to give in to
people's demands then to keep opposing their cause.
In the movie.
We see this play out when so many athletes join chuck strike than it forces all
professional sporting leagues to cancel their seasons
has now effectively destroyed professional sports plus college athletics,
High School Sport,
even such things as little league.
So far it has made a shambles of the World Cup Wimbledon and events as far away
as India and mainland China.
These protests raise social costs to the point where the public,
the media and world leaders have to pay attention.
Hello,
chuck,
and then begrudgingly take action.
In the end,
the world is radically changed,
but unlike most Hollywood movies,
this social transformation is not brought about by defeating the bad guys or
through the actions of benevolent leaders.
This social change comes from the bottom up.
It comes from people organizing and standing in solidarity together.
Harry and the Hendersons is about a typical white American family who
accidentally hit big foot with their station wagon.
Cool.
The family's relationship with this gentle giant who they named Harry ultimately
changes their lives forever.
Yeah.
This one really is better than a campy big foot movie has any right to be
over the course of the film,
the empathy that Harry demonstrates towards other living creatures inspires the
family to rethink their worldview,
especially in regards to hunting and guns.
The father played by John Lithgow,
undergoes and especially striking transformation from avid hunter and firearms
dealer to someone who over the objections of his own father,
learns to value nonviolence and embrace his creative side.
Did she drove it?
Yeah.
Beautiful
depictions of men and boys who reject guns and violence as markers of their
manhood are critically important in our current culture.
I wanted King Kong.
You brought me a God damn giant durable.
I told you exactly what to do.
He didn't even come close at all.
Maybe it's right on the nose.
I mean,
how do we know?
Maybe it's not vicious at all.
Maybe it's gentle.
Even has feelings.
Where'd you dream of that shit?
Okay.
Has this movie illustrates,
there's no reason Hollywood can't present empathy as a defining feature of
masculinity.
Yeah.
Batteries not included centers on the tenants of an Old New York City apartment
building who are resisting or real estate tycoons efforts to evict them in order
to build a skyscraper.
Yeah,
the residents are a band of down on their luck,
but kindhearted misfits who find unlikely allies in a group of mechanical aliens
looking for a place to recharge.
Our group of humans embrace their strange extraterrestrial visitors and they all
work together to help their new friends by providing fuel and energy for the
aliens reproductive process.
Good
in return,
the mechanical life forms help the residents by repairing damage done to their
building by the tycoons.
Henchman Dan,
the fixes,
they liked it.
They have that knack.
This story is really built around solidarity on all sides.
The human tenants and the alien creatures come from very different backgrounds
and have very different needs,
but they still feel for each other and work to provide mutual aid and support.
Going back and rewatching these unapologetically sincere and sentimental movies
feels like an antidote to the superficial or ironic appeals to nostalgia that
saturates much of Hollywood today.
Now I should say that none of the movies on my list are without their flaws,
like a lot of pop culture in the 1980s some include racial stereotypes and the
story's mostly focused on the experiences of white people.
Still the core themes of empathy and solidarity had a profound impact on me and
my values growing up.
My list is of course a personal one,
and therefore specific to my identity and my upbringing.
Depending on your age,
your gender,
and your cultural background,
your own list of movies,
we'll likely look quite a bit different.
Okay.
If I were making a list like this one,
but for media from this decade,
there are a handful of excellent movies that I definitely include.
I've made video essays discussing a few of them like Wally and fantastic beasts,
which you can find elsewhere on this channel,
but entertainment built around empathy and solidarity is still relatively
uncommon in 2018
which is too bad because we really need more movies that embrace their role as
empathy generating machines.
I hope you enjoyed this.
Look back at some of my favorite movies from the 1980s if you'd like to see more
of these long form video essays that examined the messages in our media,
then please consider going over to Patrion and helping to fund this project
there.
There's also a link to paypal in the description below.
Next time we'll be talking about a rather disturbing action movie trope called
abduction as romance.